neue flüchtlingswelle nach bombardements
in syrien 80.000 menschen seien auf der
flucht warnt präsident erdogan und
europa werde das zu spüren bekommen
[Musik]
staus auch bei der sanierung auf
deutschen straßen
der schlechte zustand 1000 brücken droht
für autofahrer zum sicherheitsrisiko zu
werden und knochenjob vorm
weihnachtsfest der boomende onlinehandel
wird zum alptraum für viele paketboten
nachrichten sich das heute mit christian
sieber in einem guten abend an diesem 23
dezember der start in die
weihnachtswoche hier ist alles was sie
wissen sollten über diese nachrichten
montag
und norbert hat nachher den sprung einen
schönen namen doch formiert wir beginnen
mit einer neuen drohung aus der türkei
der türkische präsident sagt die
aktuelle flüchtlingswelle aus syrien
werde auch europa zu spüren bekommen
recep tayyip erdogan spricht von mehr
als 80.000 menschen die jetzt aus syrien
unterwegs sein richtung türkei auf der
flucht vor neuen bombardements
es geht um das letzte große
rebellengebiet
und das ist die region idleb im
nordwesten von syrien seit april
umkämpft wird sie bombardiert vom
assad-regime und seinem verbündeten
russland
leidtragende sind die menschen sie
geraten immer wieder zwischen die
fronten und zigtausende wollen dem jetzt
entfliehen
die türkei muss sich auf einen zustrom
einstellen halim hosny berichtet
aufnahmen aus der umkämpften nordwest
syrischen provinz idlib vom wochenende
sie lassen ahnen welches leid die
menschen ertragen müssen weil den
angriffen der syrischen und russischen
luftwaffe sollen 21 zivilisten getötet
worden sein
die hubschrauber haben den größten
schaden angerichtet
ihre bomben haben drei viertel meines
dorfes zerstört
wir sind jetzt draußen aber wir wissen
nicht wo wir hin sollen möge gott den
menschen beistehen
an die 100.000 menschen sollen auf der
flucht sein
ihr ziel das nachbarland türkei wenn das
so weitergehe drohe eine
flüchtlingswelle vergleichbar der von
das erklärte der türkische präsident
erdogan in istanbul
wenn so etwas passiert wird die türkei
die last der migranten nicht alleine
tragen den druck den wir dann ausgesetzt
sein werden wird ein voran griechenland
und ganz besonders europa zu spüren
bekommen
3,7 millionen syrische flüchtlinge leben
in der türkei eine große last für das
land das selbst gezeichnet ist von einer
anhaltenden wirtschaftskrise die
drohungen des präsidenten findet beifall
vor allem dort wo syrer stark präsent
sind wie im istanbuler stadtteil aksaray
egal wo du hingehst überall siehst du
syrer in restaurants oder wenn ich zum
obsthändler gehe überall syrer
warum finden unsere jugendlichen keine
arbeit
wir haben keine arbeit wir können kein
brot kaufen unsere miete nicht mehr
zahlen was soll ich machen
der innenpolitische druck auf erdogan
wächst der scheint nun entschlossen ihn
an europa weiterzuleiten und präsident
erdogan macht noch auf eine andere art
druck seine grenzpolizei hindert die
flüchtlinge offenbar nicht mehr daran
nach griechenland zu gelangen
eigentlich schreibt das flüchtlings
abkommen mit der eu das vor
die migranten berichten die türkei habe
ihr vorgehen geändert allein seit
gestern erreichten hunderte von ihnen
über die igs griechische inseln aus dem
lager moria auf lesbos berichtet jetzt
annette hilsenbeck frisches brot und
bananen hussein hat eingekauft für seine
familie
vor zwei wochen sind sie im komplett
überfüllten lager moria auf lesbos
angekommen sie müssen ganz außen am rand
in olivenhainen hausen in einem
campingzelt er war schon mal in
griechenland wurde abgeschoben
jetzt hat er es wieder gewagt mit seiner
familie wir haben es drei vier mal
probiert im sommer da hat die türkische
küstenwache uns jedes mal gestoppt und
zurückgeschickt aber als wir jetzt im
dezember gekommen sind war keiner da
auch die griechischen behörden sagen
dass die türkische küste nachlasse die
flüchtlingsboote ungehindert passieren
nach den regeln des eu türkei deals ein
klarer bruch
ich denke mit den flüchtlingen in der
ägäis wird momentan ein geopolitisches
spiel gespielt
auf der türkischen seite haben wir
präsident erdogan der diese migranten
als soldaten für seine zwecke einsetzt
und nach griechenland und damit nach
europa schickt
denn erdogan will mehr geld von europa
für die aufnahme der flüchtlinge in
seinem land bis dezember 2009 10 haben
es fast 57.000 menschen aus der türkei
auf die griechischen inseln geschafft 75
prozent mehr als 2008 10
viele davon familien wie die von hussein
viele kinder und die griechische
regierung rechnet damit dass im nächsten
jahr noch mehr übers meer kommen und das
ganze bestimmt auch die diskussion in
der deutschen innenpolitik der chef der
grünen robert habeck hatte gestern
gefordert bis zu 4000 flüchtlingskinder
von den griechischen inseln nach
deutschland zu holen
baden württembergs grüner
ministerpräsident winfried kretschmann
sagte jetzt sein land sei zur aufnahme
eines sonder kontingents bereit
auch die evangelische kirche unterstützt
das sagt ihr ratsvorsitzender heinrich
bedford strohm
kritik kommt von bundesinnenminister
horst seehofer ein alleingang
deutschlands würde zu einem nicht
steuerbaren sog effekt führen und wir
bleiben auch im moment in der
innenpolitik die rente mit 63 ist
deutlich teurer als ursprünglich
angenommen
mehr als 1,3 millionen senioren beziehen
sie im moment das zeigen zahlen der
deutschen rentenversicherung
im schnitt gibt es jährlich 250.000
anträge dass es ein viertel mehr als die
bundesregierung erwartet hatte
die möglichkeit bereits mit 63 eine
abschlagsfreie rente zu beziehen gibt es
seit gut fünf jahren
voraussetzung sind mindestens 45
beitragsjahre die vereinten nationen
nennen den prozess eine farce mehr als
ein jahr nach dem mord an der
regierungskritischen journalistin
jamaika schoggi hat ein gericht in saudi
arabien fünf männer zum tode verurteilt
die ermittlungen gegen hochrangige
regierungsberater dagegen wurden
eingestellt
karrubi hatte das saudische konsulat in
istanbul besucht und papiere für seine
hochzeit abzuholen
ein spezialkommando riad tötete und
zerstückelte seine leiche
die uno fand hinweise das grundprinzip
hamid bin salman dafür verantwortlich
sein könnte weihnachten unterwegs das
bedeutet staus auch bei uns aber was in
frankreich im moment los ist stellt
alles in den schatten
der bahnstreik dort geht auch über
weihnachten weiter seit mehr als zwei
wochen gibt es dort mittlerweile schon
proteste gegen die geplante rentenreform
und das nachsehen haben jetzt auch die
die über die feiertage zu ihrer familie
oder in die ferien wollen wie miriam
steiner aus paris zeigt vor zwei monaten
hat iris lange zug ticket gekauft um
weihnachten mit ihrer familie zu
verbringen
ihr zug wurde gestrichen flüge sind
teuer und mitfahrgelegenheiten gibt es
auch nur noch eine
dann bin ich um 23 uhr da das ist ein
bisschen spät für weihnachten
aber wenn es keine andere gibt mache ich
das wie sie trifft der streik in
frankreich gerade viele leute auf dem
weg in die weihnachtsferien
denn sowohl der nahe als auch der
fernverkehr bleiben stark eingeschränkt
immer noch fallen mehr als die hälfte
der schnellzüge und 60 prozent der
regionalzüge aus und über die feiertage
wird weiter gestreikt das haben die
gewerkschafter heute morgen am gare de
lyon noch mal klar gemacht obwohl viele
das verkehrschaos inzwischen wirklich
satt haben muss sollte eine streikpause
geben
es ist doch ein bisschen einfach die
leute in geiselhaft zu nehmen so ist das
jedes mal
doch mehr als jeder zweite hier hat laut
umfragen nach wie vor verständnis für
den streik
man muss halt streiten um die sachen ins
rollen zu bringen also können wir auch
nicht meckern wir versuchen halt uns zu
organisieren organisieren das heißt
umsteigen auf teuer gewordene busse oder
leihwagen und lange staus auf den
straßen
iris langlais schreckt das nicht ab es
ist im moment im jahr wo wir alle
zusammen sind es ist nicht sehr schön in
allein in seinem kleinen studenten
zimmer zu verbringen und auch ihre
geschenke sollen ja pünktlich unterm
weihnachtsbaum liegen
die tödliche attacke auf einen
feuerwehrmann in augsburg waren nach
ansicht des landgerichts die tat eines
einzelnen des 17 jährigen
hauptverdächtigen nach auswertung des
videomaterials hat das gericht die
haftbefehle gegen die sechs anderen
festgenommenen aufgehoben sie seien
weder am totschlag beteiligt gewesen
noch hätten sie geholfen
zwei seien aber dringend tatverdächtig
das andere opfer schwer verletzt zu
haben sagt die jugendkammer und jetzt
gucken wir auf die massenproteste in
indien die immer heftiger werden mehr
als 20 menschen wurden dabei schon
getötet die proteste richten sich gegen
ein neues gesetz
der große streitpunkt die
einwanderungspolitik illegal
eingereisten migranten soll die
einbürgerung erleichtert werden
davon ausgenommen allerdings sind
muslime von den 1,3 milliarden menschen
in indien sind etwa 200 millionen
muslime
die demonstranten werfen der regierung
jetzt vor einen reinen hindu staat
errichten zu wollen florian kojak sie
gehen auf die straße für eine trennung
von staat und religion menschen
verschiedener glaubensrichtungen
befürchten das neue gesetz könnte die
gesellschaft spalten
alle von uns hindus und muslime sind
brüder und schwestern keine religion
sollte ausgegrenzt werden nicht alle
proteste bleiben friedlich am wochenende
liefern sich gewaltbereite
straßenschlachten mit der polizei
menschen sterben darunter ein 8 jähriger
junge bei einer massenpanik
premierminister modi versucht zu
beruhigen
das gesetz betrifft nicht die menschen
die hier leben
ich versichere den muslimischen bürgern
dass sich dadurch nichts für sie ändern
wird
laut modi soll das gesetz lediglich
denjenigen helfen die religiös verfolgt
werden
aus den mehrheitlich muslimischen
nachbarländern sind in den vergangenen
jahren zehntausende gekommen vor allem
um arbeit zu finden
durch das neue gesetz sollen viele von
ihnen leichter eingebürgert werden
ausgenommen muslime nun wir sehen
sicherlich dass indien sich auf dem weg
zu einem kinderstadt befindet das ist
aber auch das programm der regierung von
premierminister modi seit zwölf jahren
engagiert sich die deutsche stiftung
teilt in indien mit ihrer hilfe lernen
zehntausende flüchtlings und
straßenkinder unter anderem lesen und
schreiben doch nun ist das projekt in
gefahr
wir sind sehr beunruhigt die
muslimischen bauarbeiter auf unserer
baustelle in kohat boden bereits
vertrieben und wir fürchten auch um die
sicherheit unserer deutschen mitarbeiter
und haben deswegen entschieden diese nun
von dort zu evakuieren
eine entspannung der lage ist derzeit
nicht in sicht sie werden weiter auf die
straße gehen in der hoffnung dass
bürgerrechte nicht an religion gebunden
werden schönheit so nennt russlands
präsident wladimir putin die brücke die
russland mit der krim verbindet als
illegal bezeichnet sie die eu und die
usa seit einem jahr rollen hier schon
die autos seit heute auch der
bahnverkehr im lokführer haus des ersten
zuges der präsident höchstpersönlich 19
kilometer misst die brücke und ist damit
die längste in russland und europa und
wohl auch die umstrittenste russlands
annexion der krim vor fünf jahren wird
international scharf kritisiert brücken
bei uns jeder merkte der viel unterwegs
ist werden zunehmend zum problem es geht
oft nur langsam voran manchmal einspurig
und ab und zu ist der weg ganz versperrt
mehr als 2000 autobahnbrücken in
deutschland sind dringend
sanierungsbedürftig die bundesregierung
und baufirmen kommen mit dem ausbessern
nicht hinterher und so hat sich der
zustand zuletzt noch weiter
verschlechtert
das ist nicht nur ärgerlich sondern auch
ein sicherheitsrisiko berichtet ute
waffenschmidt
hier wird es eng auf der
autobahnauffahrt zur rheinbrücke bei
leverkusen pkw dürfen noch durch die
vorgegebenen spuren lkw werden vor der
auffahrt ab und umgeleitet denn die
brücke ist marode kann den
schwerlastverkehr nicht mehr verkraften
bundesweit sind und 2000 brücken
sanierungsbedürftig wir haben da unter
anderem für 2020 780 millionen euro
vorgesehen
bis 2023 59 millionen das heißt wir sind
hier auf einem guten weg und investieren
massiv im programm rücken modernisierung
aber reichlich spät die meisten brücken
stamme aus den sechzigerjahren damalige
planungen sind längst von der
wirklichkeit überholt mehr verkehr und
viel schwerere laster haben den
bauwerken stark zugesetzt
nach dem einsturz der morandi brücke in
genua 2018 hat deutschland die
sicherheitsauflagen verschärft das
hauptproblem ist eigentlich dass die
politik zu lange
die empfehlungen der experten ignoriert
hat und erst reagiert hat als die ersten
brücken für lkws gesperrt werden müssen
da hat man wertvolle zeit verschenkt die
man jetzt aufholen muss es fehlen aber
fachleute die diese masse an brücken die
neu geplant werden müssen und auch
saniert werden müssen
dort umsetzen können geld ist also da
aber die umsetzung dauert in leverkusen
soll eine neue autobahn brücke gebaut
werden
geschätzte fertigstellung 2025
entwarnung auf den galapagos inseln nach
einem schiffsunfall konnte eine
umweltkatastrophe verhindert werden
der ölteppich ist inzwischen unter
kontrolle vor der insel san cristobal
war ein kran beim beladen eines schiffes
umgekippt das schiff ist daraufhin
gesunken
die besatzung konnte sich retten das
schiff hatte rund 2500 liter diesel
geladen
seit 1978 zählen die inseln zum
unesco-weltnaturerbe die artenvielfalt
dort gilt als weltweit einzigartig so
morgen ist heiligabend und alle jahre
wieder bedeutet das halt auch stress für
die die noch geschenke suchen und für
die die geschenke liefern
dreimal so viele pakete wie sonst
liefern deutschlands zusteller jeden tag
im moment 11,6 millionen stück jeden tag
wie gesagt großer stress für kleinen
lohn je nach von über 200 pakete am tag
muss dirk schröder in der
vorweihnachtszeit ausliefern
fast doppelt so viele wie sonst darunter
gibt es auch sehr schwere brocken manche
wiegen sogar über 30 kilo eine
körperliche herausforderung für viele
paketfahrer ziemlich anstrengend weil
mehr pakete viele schwere pakete und so
hat schlaucht ganz schön mich freuen vor
weihnachten dann weiter entspannen kann
bei familie zu hause nicht immer sind
die kunden da
dirk schröder ist dankbar wenn dann die
nachbarn aushelfen jost knapp nimmt oft
pakete an um vor allem den paket fahrrad
zu entlasten
ich habe eigentlich das gefühl für
unterbezahlt sind ich schleppte sich
hier ganz schön ab und ich sehe auch
immer dass die ziemlich im stress sind
13 eur 65 brutto die stunde verdient
dirk schröder nach tarif in dieser
branche gibt es aber auch schwarze
schafe andere unternehmen bei denen
überstunden nicht bezahlt werden und
dadurch der mindestlohn von 9 eur 19
nicht eingehalten wird und dieser ist
für die gewerkschaften ohnehin zu gering
der mindestlohn muss steigen und zwar
schnell auf 12 euro und in der
paketzustellung wird viel zu wenig nach
tarif bezahlt da ist dr
da sind da die großen wie hermes und dpd
aber die meist nur mit einem kleinen
teil der beschäftigten unter
tarifverträge fallen
das heißt es braucht mehr tarif schutz
dirk schröder bekommt überstunden
bezahlt überstunden ohne die er in
diesen tagen die große flut an
weihnachtspaketen gar nicht
bewerkstelligen könnte der staat in die
weihnachtswoche dazu gehört in dresden
traditionell
der größte gottesdienst unter freiem
himmel in deutschland tausende menschen
kommen jedes jahr vor die frauenkirche
und dann kann weihnachten beginnen
[Musik]
schön und der sport da wir beginnen mit
fußball in der premier league trafen
zwei champions league-gegner deutscher
mannschaften aufeinander
chelsea und tottenham 2 0 endete das
londoner stadtduell das aber ein
nachspiel hat wegen rassistischer
anfeindungen gegen chelsea verteidiger
antonio rüdiger 60 c minute tottenham
svensson mit diesem tritt gegen antonio
rüdiger unbestritten eine tätlichkeit
rüdiger fällt allerdings auch sehr
theatralisch nach den berechtigten
platzverweis für sonn wird chelseas
deutscher nationalspieler aus dem
tottenham blog mehrfach rassistisch
beleidigt meldet sich beim
schiedsrichter und nach der partie per
twitter zu wort
ich hoffe dass die täter schnell
gefunden und bestraft werden das muss in
solch einem modernen stadion wie in
tottenham mit den vielen kameras einfach
möglich sein top team selbst hat
inzwischen eine untersuchung des
vorfalls eingeleitet nachdem trainer
mourinho sofort stellung bezogen hat ich
hasse rassismus ob in der gesellschaft
allgemein oder im fußball und bin sehr
sehr enttäuscht dass so etwas immer noch
passieren kann
sportlich ist chelsea klar besser
million erzielt beide tore für bayerns
gegner im champions league achtelfinale
durch das 0 2 fällt tottenham auf das
leipzig in der champions league trifft
in der premier league auf platz 7 zurück
während chelsea durch den ersten sieg
nach zwei niederlagen nacheinander
platz vier behaupten kann
fortuna düsseldorf hat den vertrag mit
trainer friedhelm funkel bis sommer 2021
verlängert
das neue arbeitspapier für den 66 jahre
alten coach gilt aber nur im fall des
klassenerhalts am saisonende
ja und jetzt noch einen blick auf die
darts wm in london im legendären ally
pally nach max hopp und gabriel clemens
ist nun auch der letzte deutsche
ausgeschieden
nico kurz der den kürzeren zog in der
dritten runde gegen den engländer luke
humphries auftritt zum größten match
seiner karriere im mekka des reitsports
dem ally pally in london
nico kurz gegen die nummer 46 der welt
luke humphries der 22 jährige kurz
startet furios ihm gelingt der erste
180er drei würfe in die dreifach 20
hintereinander die höchstpunktzahl wenig
später versenkt er den pfeil zur 2 zu 1
satzführung das wm-achtelfinale in
greifbarer nähe
er hat all das gebiet ahnt ein paar
richtig gute spieler geschlagen und
hätte er seine chance im fünften satz
genutzt würde er jetzt hier sitzen und
seinen sieg feiern
satz 5 die wände um wenige zentimeter
verpasst nico kurz das bullseye den
satzgewinn
danach läuft nicht mehr viel zusammen am
ende triumphiert humphries mit 4 2
sätzen
[Applaus]
wenn man glaubt eigentlich immer noch
daran irgendwie die kurve zu bekommen
aber mit dem druck den ich von look
bekommen habe war es natürlich schwer
dann irgendwie damit umzugehen
ich habe mein bestes gegeben und
sensation verpasst trotz sensationellen
wm debüt nico kurz hat gezeigt hier
wächst eine run der defense in ally
pally noch häufig begeistern dürfte das
war es von mir
norbert haben noch zwei ungewöhnliche
buspassagiere in den usa in einer bucht
in der nähe von seattle haben sich wieso
zwei seelöwen ein plätzchen zum kuscheln
gesucht und mit ihren 800 kilo ein boot
fast zum kentern gebracht
ein angler hat die beiden besonderen
hobby segler entdeckt und natürlich
sofort gefilmt und so city seelöwen über
nacht zu internet- stars geworden und
ihr video wurde mehr als eine million
mal angeklickt könnte ich glatt nochmal
gucken wetter von weißer weihnacht sind
wir weit entfernt in deutschland
ungemütlich und nass wird es bei uns an
heiligabend tut mir leid die details hat
gleich osten terry ich empfehle ihnen
das heute schon ein mit dem kollegen
claus kleber um 21 50
das team der 19 uhr heute nachrichten
ist selbstverständlich auch morgen an
heiligabend für sie da bis dann wenn sie
mögen und ihnen einen angenehmen abend
tschüss
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter ein neues tief
kündigt regen an und das kommt vom
ostatlantik rüber gerauscht nach
deutschland bringt erneut regen sehen
ist sie in blau und weiß das ist schnee
allerdings eher in den alpen schauen uns
das mal genauer an in der nacht regnet
es in der mitte oder auch im süden an
den alpen schneit es durchaus und ganz
im norden fallen auch einige tropfen
sonst ist es trocken weil ein bis sieben
grad im westen und morgen am vormittag
da kommen die wolken von westen wieder
mal reingezogen ansonsten im osten ist
es trocken hier zeigt sich mal die sonne
genau so wie im südosten
am nachmittag wird das noch ein bisschen
ungemütlicher hier kommt auch noch
kräftiger südwestwind auf schnee fällt
oberhalb von 700 metern in den östlichen
mittelgebirgen
die temperaturen steigen auf 5 grad im
vogtland und sehr milden 13 grad im
südwesten deutschlands die nächsten tage
am ersten feiertag wird es relativ
durchwachsen seien mit regen und schnee
aber dann erst über 600 meter in 4 bis
10 grad die höchstwerte am zweiten
feiertag ist es relativ ruhig und nicht
mehr so nass bei zwei bis sieben grad
damit wünsche ihnen einen schönen abend
und schöne feiertage